foreign
this view is way more intimidating
Tristan uh very warm welcome back to
Stanford GSB it's a great pleasure and
honor to have you
thanks for everything as I was
researching your fascinating story for
this interview Tristan I was most
impressed by the refreshing Candor of
the mission you set for yourself when
you were just a young boy
back then the ambition you had was not
to change lives change organizations
change the world but rather something
more pragmatic which was in your words
to become as wealthy as possible as
quickly as possible that's right
that's right well done well done could
you share with us how your operating
shape that ambition of yours yeah
um glad to be here
we were broke
and as you said I realized I had one
goal in life that was good as wealthy as
possible as quickly as possible the
story that I I share I had three outlets
for that
uh the first was to be an actor or an
athlete
didn't work
the second way was to work on Wall
Street which I had the great Fortune to
do and I'll kind of tell you how I got
there in a second
but it didn't work
and then ultimately I realized that
there was this third one called
entrepreneurship and kind of is working
um look my ambition was quite humble
right I realized I was a victim of bad
circumstance I was a victim of bad
situation the victim of bad culture and
realized that I had something in me to
create good circumstance good culture a
lot of which I learned from here at
Stanford I had a good fortune when I was
in high school to go to one of the top
high schools in the country a boarding
school on full rides called the
Hotchkiss School in Lakeville
Connecticut
um and it was the first time I got to
see how the other half lived
I went to school with Rockefellers and
Fords and I think the most
transformative point of that experience
for me is that I recognized the value of
name
right just like we had Rockefellers and
Fords what does Walker represent for
people what are the values that kind of
come with that name that I want to
purport right
um and you know really that experience
was really formative for every single
thing that I've done from then to date
and has carried with me ever since
still want to get as wealthy as possible
as quickly as possible that has not
changed but there are some things that
kind of came along with that I.E kind of
firmness around values that really do
matter to me and explain the majority of
my story
and tell us about your your path to Wall
Street
oh Jesus
um
this idea of like desire right I think
it's also important to talk a little bit
about like why I wanted to get as
wealthy as possible as quickly as
possible right
um you know we think about like desire
as this kind of straight line this thing
between like what we think we want
versus the thing that we desire but
desire doesn't really work that way it
tends to work through a model of
influence right I want that thing I want
the money I want the drip I want like
all that stuff because these models of
influence these celebrities these wall
streeters and the nice suits made me
want to desire that thing I realized
very quickly when I wanted to be an
actor an athlete didn't work out for me
because I was also good at math and I
realized that that conversion rate
wasn't going to work as effectively as I
wanted it to but I did see those models
of influence on television wearing the
nice suits working on Wall Street and
they had the money and I was very much a
kind of New England baby I didn't know
anything about Silicon Valley I didn't
know anything kind of West of New York
so I gravitated toward where the money
was and it was that I worked at Lehman
Brothers and JP Morgan
um did that for about two years and I
was miserable
um you know I talked about being the
victim of bad culture I was that
um I got laid off this was 2008.
um I got laid off in January of 2008. uh
fun fact that I've never talked about to
this day I don't even think I I told
Derek that the day I got laid off this
is about seven or eight in the morning
in January
um I got on the phone
um and I was expecting to kind of get
this this story from kind of my manager
and I get on the phone with the person
who calls my phone and there's this
number that I didn't know right
um telling me this story
um you know high anxiety I'm like what's
going on here
um and this gentleman on the phone was
like
wait wait wait wait wait Tristan uh this
is Derek Bolton from Stanford University
like you were admitted to Stanford
Business School right
um it was fascinating even like a couple
hours after that then kind of my manager
kind of laid me off also said you know
we're going to give you a bonus oh right
because it was around bonus season and
we're going to give you nine months of
severance right so you talk about kind
of this idea of like having faith and um
you know just being thankful uh you know
that was the kind of real wonderful
informative moment for me but Wall
Street just didn't work they put had the
wrong person in the wrong situation at
the wrong time and I'm very very
grateful to have been ejected from that
industry indeed great timing and
speaking this wonderful time GSB this is
where you got your first taste of
Entrepreneurship as a second year MBA
student you were working pretty much
full-time for a promising new startup at
the time called Foursquare the story of
how you landed that opportunity with
Foursquare offers us a lesson in
persistence tell us how you got that job
yeah so um in between my first and
second year of physical and this was
around the time when Stanford was
starting on the GSB was starting its new
curriculum which is you know uh
particularly challenging we had a rule
that you couldn't do anything
extracurricular at Stanford
um during your first quarter or two I
didn't listen and I did it anyway
um so the first year I actually joined
this company called Twitter at the time
there were about 20 people at the
company we had like fewer than a million
users at the time and I saw the way that
it was changing communication I got
really excited about it so much so a lot
of my kind of GSB classmates were like
what is this like nobody cares
about this thing you're crazy to even
kind of desire it but I knew that I had
to be a part of that action I mean that
was really my first foray into kind of
what Silicon Valley could be in between
my first and second year at business
school I worked for Boston Consulting
Group uh did that for about half the
summer because I wanted to do this
Twitter thing for the second half of the
summer and Stanford gave me some Grace
to do that there's a little bit of drama
in the beginning but they gave me some
Grace to do that and at that time I
heard about this company called
Foursquare so in the same way that
Twitter helped me really think about the
changing landscape of communication
Foursquare helped me really think about
kind of my connection to place in a way
that got me really excited Foursquare
had two employees at the time we had
like 8 000 users and I was just
genuinely you know authentically excited
about what they were building The Story
Goes I found the founders emails on the
internet Dennis and Naveen uh email them
eight times the eighth time Dennis gets
back to me he says you know what I just
may take you up on some of this or you
have in New York I was in LA at the time
working for a BCG and I looked over to
my wife and I said wow how I'm going to
reply to this I just emailed this guy
like eight times and finally like he
gets back to me I replied back I said
yes I'll be in New York tomorrow
I booked my flight that night flew out
the following morning hung out with them
for a week and a month later I was
running business development for the
company and that completely changed my
life Wow completely changed my life I
showed up at the door he wasn't thinking
I was going to come I showed up at the
door opened the door and there's a look
of just like a surprise like who is this
dude and I sat down and got to work and
it completely changed everything for me
and I'm most grateful for that
you said you sent eight emails correct
to the founder of Foursquare before you
got a reply uh for all of us Hustlers
out there in your professional opinion
how many follow-up emails
are we permitted to send before we cross
the line I think this is
it probably was going to be my last one
right um and you know it's again a
testament to to Faith I think
um
authenticity matters in this like
there's no kind of set and hard rule I
knew I had to be a part of that movement
right my life has been really about
movement work
right only doing the things that kind of
adhere to the personal values that I had
and Foursquare was movement work Twitter
was movement work now looking in
hindsight people like yeah of course
Twitter right um but it wasn't that
obvious back then
um and I think especially in the GSB
context you know I was Jeff uh talked a
little bit about the classes that we had
previously you know you'll find that a
lot of business school classmates Chase
sameness
with the same jobs for the same roles
right and little do we realize that that
sameness creates conflict because you're
chasing these finite resources and that
conflict leads to violence right
um and I think for me I think the thing
that kind of stood out was my difference
I was not chasing the thing that other
people were chasing I was chasing the
things that lived with my values and the
wonderful thing about values is that
they're infinite you know I can't keep
courage to myself I can't keep
inspiration to myself I can't keep
loyalty myself those are things that can
be infinitely shared right so I try to
gravitate all of the things that I
choose to do to be in line with the
values that I have so you know one
lesson to be had here is you know send
us any emails as you want as long as
you're authentically committed to
following through what you're saying in
those emails and that is a missing link
that I think a lot of folks don't
understand
wonderful after a three-year stint at
Foursquare he joined Andreessen Horowitz
in 2012 as an entrepreneur in Residence
tasked with brainstorming big ideas for
a future business so how did you
eventually settle on the idea of shaving
products for people of color yeah I was
there for the The Jig was you have six
to nine months to figure out the company
you want to start right it's crazy I got
paid to do that it's like absurd it's
the best job I've ever had I spent seven
months there wasting their time
I spent seven months wasting their time
here's what I mean by that I was chasing
the thing that I felt would make them
proud to support me with
it's very like business school thing you
know I see a business model that needs
disruption let me go do it and show how
smart I am
right
um so I was chasing things that I had no
business doing I remember I had one idea
to like change the way we thought about
Trucking in this country
I don't know about the trucking
I've never been at a kind of truck stop
to speak with truckers right but I had
this idea Commerce moves on trucks and
it should be more efficient and that's
when like uber was getting started right
like oh this is smart and um yeah I
remember going down you know all these
VC shops on Sandhill Road as this
entries and horror it's entrepreneur in
Residence and yeah I thought I'd just
walk in and kind of own the place right
and a lot of these VCS who say great
idea go after it and when I'd show up at
injuries and harness they say no it's a
terrible idea right and I come up with
another idea and I go down Sand Hill
Road and they say go after it and
address and Howard State yeah that's a
terrible idea and the I think the lesson
that I learned the first idea that
Andreessen Harvest said you know it's a
great idea was the one that they felt
that I was uniquely positioned to do
um it was a real great lesson for me
where I recognized that each of us in
this room
has something that we are uniquely
positioned to do that we are singularly
the best person in the world to try to
solve that was based on your own lived
experience it was the first idea at
least as I think about Walker and
Company and I'll kind of talk about how
I kind of got to that that entries and
Horowitz said great and everybody else
said no and it was the first time in my
life I started here no
and I knew that there was an opportunity
in that right usually what looks like
good ideas or bad ideas usually looks
like bad ideas are good ideas the
problem with good ideas is that too many
people try to do them sameness right and
it wasn't until I came over this bad
idea difference that the Breakthrough
kind of happened
um now shaving you know I spent the
majority of my life shaving with
products that you know we were relegated
to having to use that didn't work for me
and I just got fed up I actually came
into this idea authentically not as like
a business model I was actually somewhat
embarrassed I was like you know do I
want to be building the thing for black
folks as the black guy in Silicon Valley
and doing the obvious thing and it
wasn't until I embraced that difference
that like really things started to take
off for me I'm just being like straight
up and honest about it but it really
started with this hey I needed a better
way to shave in every single way I
encountered facial hair removal sucked
you know down to the experience of
walking into these retail aisles seeing
dirty boxes with dudes with Jerry curls
on the box in the packaging right it
didn't really reflect kind of like
um the culture that I respected so much
and I felt when I talked about this idea
of unique difference not only did I have
authentically the problem that I was
trying to solve for myself I was one of
the few black folks in Silicon Valley at
a major Venture Capital firm that really
liked the idea so in 2013 I felt like I
was the best person in the world to
start this company I would not say that
in 2023
but in 2013 I was and the rest is
history
well the idea you articulated just now
sounds like a no-brainer after all when
you think about it people of color need
shaving products too
go figure
you know established Brands like
Gillette and others have been around for
many many years in the case of July I
believe over a century why is it that
they haven't already exploited the
market opportunity you wisely identify
yeah I mean capitalism is a cool game
some of it is about incentives
um you know our technology was built on
100 year old technology right we just
encourage people to shave with single
blade razors
you know this is how you know I when I
really I had one kind of interesting
experience around the time that I was at
injuries in Horowitz
um you know I was shaving so I'm
satisfied I walked into an Art of
Shaving store I don't even know if it's
still here at Stanford Shopping mall
right down the street I walked into the
store I said hey I've had to deal with
this issue related to like razor bumps
and that stuff my entire life what
should I use
um and the Art of Shaving is owned a
time but Procter and Gamble right and
they have all the incentive in the world
to take me to those like three four five
six blade multi-blade razors that you
know with the nice handle on it where
they can get their margin that sort of
thing and um I did this at this store I
also did it one in DC they never took me
to any of those products they always
took me to use these off-brand single
blade double-edged safety razors so I
tried it woke up the following day and
was the first experience of my life
where I didn't have razor bumps on my
face and I knew that there was a
breakthrough I said why is this the case
right I started to kind of learn a
little bit more about the history of
shaving and I learned everything started
about 100 years ago with a single blade
double-edged safety razor it cuts the
hair level with the skin not beneath
your skin so if you have curly hair it's
just going to grow into your skin so
really effective for that it's one clean
cut so no pulling or tugging obvious
stuff right
you think about starting that in the
year 1900 20 years later uses the patent
for it right then you make a two blade
razor and 20 years after that you lose
the patent for it and you make a three
blade razor 20 years after that you lose
the patent for it then you make a four
blade razor but the thing that they had
started with was the most efficacious
thing for anyone to use so why would
they ever be incentivized to go make
that again where they can't maintain and
secure their margin so it was a good
kind of lesson for me around like
innovators dilemma type stuff right and
we're able to kind of package that in a
bow because we knew how to speak to the
consumer that we were targeting because
I was representative of that same
consumer so why weren't they able to do
it I think there's a little bit of that
but also
um you know if you're a brand manager at
any of these companies
um and you're making 80 billion dollars
a year in Revenue you're going to chase
any new kind of innovation you're going
to want to see a realization of like a
billion dollars of return in the first
couple years
so you're going to get some brand
manager who says okay
um you know let's look at black men
shaving the United States right
200 million dollar industry
so that same brand manager is going to
say well even if we captured like 100 of
that market share it's not big enough
and I realize that perhaps that person
asked the wrong question
um because the reason the market is so
small is because you make things that
don't work for it
you know and until like you can start to
articulate that reason why and actually
have a new kind of different product for
it I thought about Market expansion as
opposed to just value capture so those
two things I think caught a lot of the
competition on their back foot which is
why we were able to innovate so quickly
notwithstanding the intense conviction
you so clearly displayed when it came to
raising money Venture Capital firms were
not exactly enthused by your idea
initially many of us in the audience may
have pitched or planned to pitch VCS how
did your first pitch event go I am
I hate raising money
I I think
um every single mistake that I've ever
made as an entrepreneur as a result of
my having raised money I think that
there is an incredible
um incentive mismatch
behind the kind of muddied interest and
what you want to create you know I
wanted to build something that was going
to be around 100 years from now but VCS
need their return in 10 years right so
it creates like this weird situation
so for me I had to adapt and shift my
pitch in a way that didn't make sense
for the long-term outcome for the
business but put me in a position to
just raise that money right
um so you know we were pitching this
well we're going to be a director
consumer brand that like celebrates
culture and it's there's technology
right but ultimately we're a consumer
package goods company
um I remember you know I talked a little
bit about walking down those consumer
retail aisles and getting packaging that
looked dirty and the guy with the Jerry
curl and all that other stuff and
um you know folks would laugh
right and then my first slide would be
that package
and they would all shut up right and I
think that is indicative of the
difficulty that I had because folks had
their assumptions
for what it was like to shop as a black
person
um as a non-black person you know and
they couldn't kind of
um rid themselves of those assumptions
as I was pitching so you're pitching to
venture capitalists who don't understand
pitching to a lot of venture capitalists
who don't want to understand
and that's where the difficulty came in
and you know you ask enough people you
get a couple who will give you some
money but when I kind of compare our
situation versus other competitors in
the space that focus on the mass Market
in our our the amount that we raise and
the amount of support that we got pales
in comparison now in the face of this
pushback you described from investors
how were you able to maintain the
confidence that your idea is the right
one the problem lies with these
investors who just don't have the right
contacts or who don't understand the
market of the product yeah there's
nothing that they could tell me because
I felt like I was the best person in the
world to solve that thing I lived the
problem
right I don't need to convince you you
know like I've already convinced myself
and I'm going to make my life a little
bit better
and I think that's something that's kind
of carried with me ever since now I also
want to say like I'm I'm up here
um speaking from view from the top a
person of incredible privilege right
yeah I raised some 39 million dollars
but look I mean I when someone inside
boarding schools in the country on full
ride I'm a Stanford GSB person right
like I was an entrepreneur in Residence
at injury scenaro it's
um so you know my situation was a hell
of a lot
easier than some others so I want to
kind of acknowledge and respect the
privilege that I've received there
um but it's hard
it is hard but there is no convincing
that I wasn't solving a problem that was
not only important to me right when I
show up in offices with razor bumps on
my face for an interview the sapping of
confidence and my ability to convert
into getting the job that I want if you
were in the military and have to shave
every single day there's actually
studies that talk about how your
performance is impacted by like your the
pain that comes from the raisons that
are on your face right so I had a story
that was wholly authentic and it was my
goal at that point to find other folks
that actually kind of felt what I felt
and look I mean while this is a problem
that 30 percent of black men and women
have or 80 of black men want to have 30
of everyone else has it eventually I
found some people who had it yeah and
you were able to find some other folks
including high profile investors people
like Carmelo Anthony John Legend Magic
Johnson how did you Market yourself and
your brand to these big name investors
given your limited public profile at the
time yeah I mean the the interesting
thing about
um those folks is they shop at the same
place as I do
it's not like special Health and Beauty
Store for NBA players who can't find
solutions for their shaving needs you
know they've had the same experience
their entire lives and they have someone
who looks like them that respects and
understands the culture and speaks the
language and kind of knows what he's
talking about might be a good Steward
for my capital and they gave it to me
and and that's why I say at that point
they weren't hearing stories like that
from anybody else from someone that
reflected that same diversity
authenticity authentically so I was able
to convert those folks a hell of a lot
better than I was able to convert other
folks but now we're in a position where
there's so many folks that do the sorts
of things that I do that like they're
spreading their Capital
um to support folks like me back in
2013. but it was a real easy pitch man
and and frankly those were some of the
easier pitches that lasted five minutes
because they got it right away and I
didn't have to explain it so now that
you've secured a financial cushion from
these investors you could then focus on
scaling your business including getting
your products onto the shelves of
retailers like Target and Walmart
what new skills did you have to develop
as you transition from founder to
operator
that's a good question
um I've had to reflect on this quite a
bit because there's a lot of
entrepreneurs who would come to my
office and
you know ask me for advice like I say I
want to start a company like how can I
raise money and all that stuff and um
you know I always ask them a question in
return and I say all right oh you want
to start a company but do you want to
run it
and no one has ever had an answer to
that question immediately
you know 90 of my job is just people
stuff you know like I don't focus on any
product stuff anymore
um and you know I I learned at least in
my role is that I get to go through
something that 99 of the world does not
I've gotten to go through layoffs
terminations
raising up rounds raising down rounds
being very close to running out of money
lawsuits and all that
um and I Relish in it in the
quasi-stagistic way but like it actually
having gone through it now it makes me
wise on the other side you know the
thing that I hated most was getting
advice from VCS who never did anything
you know
um getting advice from operators who
didn't do the thing that like I'm asking
for advice for but now having gone
through it now I can actually say that
there is a difference between being a
founder and an operator
um you know Ben Howard's uh you know
prepared me for this he said you know
being a CEO sucks
is the worst job I've ever had
it is the worst job that I've ever had
but I can't see myself doing anything
else you know like there's something I
think powerful and inspiring about
having gone through all that stuff that
makes me a better father
it makes me a better brother
it makes me a better manager it makes me
a better friend right because I've had
to live that difficulty
um so that's how I try to articulate it
to people that might not understand it I
try to prepare them
for how much it sucks so that they'll be
ready to like show up when their people
need them right and I would imagine
running a business as you allude to
comes with its fair share of
disappointments what were some of the
major setbacks you faced and how did you
overcome them
I'll start in 2018 2018 was the worst
year of my life frankly it started
really in that way and ended wonderfully
on December 12th 2018 we announced our
acquisition by Procter Gamble which was
a kind of great and wonderful moment
um look I sit on the stage and you know
folks before like wow that's probably a
pretty successful guy right
um but ultimately that was a year when
we were close to running out of money if
we didn't get that acquisition we
probably wouldn't be around three months
after that right
um you know we couldn't raise any money
we had to do a Down Round I had to do a
reduction in force I was the guy it's
2018 and I was around 35 or so 34 or
something like that I got shingles
right for folks of you who are not
familiar with it if you've had
chickenpox before right like the only
reason you would ever get shingles is
because of stress something and it was
the first time when I heard that
diagnosis I realized that there was a
difference between what I felt and what
was actually happening to me right
um I started therapy around that time I
did therapy for about six months by the
time we sold the company and my
therapist was like Tristan when you
started here
you didn't do the layoff
right you didn't have the down round
you were not speaking to any of these
companies for potential acquisition
you didn't know that you were going to
have your second kid
right you didn't like move or think
about moving to Atlanta like these are
all happening all at the same time right
um that was a terrible terrible terrible
moment but it really taught me about how
much Faith actually matters
right and if you kind of stick to the
gun stick to the values know that you've
been here before and have values that'll
guide kind of your decision making
moving forward it'll end up in an okay
place and unfortunately it did for us
but I was well prepared by that time
knowing that like the stuff sucks
it sucks but you can get to the other
side quite nicely
when you sold your company in 2018 to
Procter and Gamble for
an undisclosed but presumably large sum
of money
you don't have to tell us how much it's
okay
although if you'd like to you're welcome
to
uh
when you sold your company to PNG you
became the first black CEO of a PNG
subsidiary what does that Milestone mean
to you
um
it's meaningful
I've shared the story
um quite a bit
and it was a story of when I first saw
our products show up in Target stores
so if you heard this before I apologize
that I'm repeating it but it really does
matter
um we started selling our products in
Target stores in 2016.
we started our distribution in February
of that year
we're really busy at the time we were
launching new products so I couldn't see
what our products look like when we
started there
so about April or May of of that year I
said let me go to
Target and see what's up you know make
sure that they put our stuff on shelves
in the right way and I took my oldest at
the time he was two his name's Avery and
we went to uh the Target in Mountain
View California
and so I put him in the cart and we
turned into the aisle
and we get about a quarter of the aisle
down and my son points behind me and he
says Dada right
and one of our boxes was turned around
and I was on the box so he saw me and
was like dada
and you know there's two things that um
I thought about in that moment
knowing that he wasn't going to realize
it as a two-year-old but over time
ultimately he will
number one his dad is on the box
you know
um particularly coming from a culture
that is appreciated for its kind of
consumer influence we're less respected
for our ability to produce
and you know here's my son a black
two-year-old who can look at that and
say my dad made that
and I can be respected as much as a
producer as I am as a consumer
and I second you know we weren't in this
ethnic Beauty aisle with like the
packaging at the bottom and having it be
dirty and all that stuff it matters like
we were above Gillette you know
um
and you know when I think about the
meaning of being like the first black
CEO in 180 year history when we when we
acquired we're taking it to the
boardroom of Procter and Gamble I love
the company
um and in their Board Room is like this
mahogany walled office and there's a
painting
of every single PNG CEO since the
beginning of time and there are like 15
paintings
right and there's um
it's a profound impact like being in
that room like wow these are like
excellent people that worked for an
excellent organization that has
sustained itself excellently for a long
period of time
and there's a picture of me under like
Procter and Gamble they're like right
next to each other and I think that like
the juxtaposition of that was really
meaningful and Powerful because now
we're in a position to scale Avery's
story to the world
right now he can produce
you know who's going to be that first
painting that looks markedly different
from every single other one that's on
the wall
and that is a story that I think
our acquisition makes possible
and I'm only hopeful that we see more of
that over time but that's what it means
to me and it really started with that
kind of innocent Target story
I have a final question for you Tristan
before we turn it over to the audience
you are the protagonist of a GSB case
study called the extroverted introvert
what does it mean to be an extroverted
introvert and how has that disposition
helped you personally and professionally
that's a great question I um
I am an introvert that recognized that
my job requires my extroversion I'm just
not naturally a sociable dude you know
and you know I find that it takes a lot
of energy for me to show up but it's a
part of my job right so I kind of
understand that and respect it and know
that I have to do that excellently as
well
um the way I've been able to cope with
that though
um is I've curated my life in a way that
is very deliberate
um around the time I started my company
I went to Starbucks in El Camino Real
down here right down the street you Veer
right and I spent 45 minutes writing
down my personal values
and they were follows courage
inspiration respect judgment wellness
and loyalty I Define them at that moment
I said I'm going to make every decision
I am going to hire people I am only
going to have a set of friends that
share those values
right you find that there are a few
people that have ever done that and they
find themselves wasting a lot of time
and expending more energy than they need
to so I think I've done a good job
curating my life around those folks who
share those values which minimizes the
my requirements I have to be someone I'm
not
and be around people that give me
permission to continue to be myself
knowing that I have that kind of
introversion about me
but I'll do this in Delight because I
have to do it excellently and I have a
job you know but I think a bit of my
power or my superpower has been like
knowing who I am and curating my life
around not having to be who I'm not
and would you say there are certain
personal attributes or qualities that
are more conducive to success I don't
think so I think it's um consistency
just be consistent about the things that
um you value
you know I was telling one of the
classes that I was teaching at was like
man where I came from if you're loyal
like you could die you know what I mean
like that stuff that is carried with me
every single time so like you know if
I've ever had a colleague who moves on
and does something else like maybe like
Tristan was a loyal dude you know like
that stuff matters to me I want folks to
know that I did things courageously
right when you're with me or when you
leave like it's a courageous dude and I
think consistency really is the thing
that matters most
consistency I love it thank You Tristan
for sharing with us your wisdom today
would you like to take a few questions
from the audience sure please okay
hello yes
hi I'm Samuel secretary Samuel Samuel
cool that's second year MBA uh my
question is do you believe in the future
of more diverse brands or in a future of
a diversity of Brands crafted to single
groups
oh
um
I believe in a future where people will
choose to gravitate
towards brands people entities that
share their values
I think we're in a bit of a like cool
Renaissance right now
um where only bevel Walker company can
exist because we make space for people
to like reclaim their own values again
um I don't think the world needs more
brands
it needs more authenticity and
consistency
right we have enough Brands there's like
a million brands that you can go to but
like what about you kind of establishes
that connection people will buy Gillette
that's fine right like there are enough
people to buy bevel too
um and I think the trick will come for
Founders to not chase the greed right
versus like finding your tribe and kind
of going in so I think the future is the
founders who care about the tribes that
they want to build and sticking with it
because that's a big enough opportunity
does that answer the question
cool
they got her working out
hi I'm Alexa we met earlier when you
were in my path to power class and you
had mentioned that you asked one
question in interviews you ask people
what's the hardest thing you've ever
been through so I wanted to turn that
back to you
oh yeah oh that's a good question uh so
so I shared that uh you know I usually
ask kind of you know one question
um
during my interviews uh usually by the
time that folks kind of come to me the
team has really vetted you know can the
person do the job right
um so I tend to ask that question
because I think it gets at the heart of
like values very quickly
right
um and you know I've interviewed
hundreds and hundreds of folks and I've
only had one person like tell me
something work related
which is a bit interesting right because
you think that folks would try to say
right like let me prove that I'm smart
but folks really like will get to the
heart of
um everything and talk about divorce
they've talked about deaths and family
right have folks cry on the other side
of the table and one thing that I do
after they articulate the story I try
and recite it back to them kind of in
line with the values that we have and
then we have like a really wonderful
conversation and they tell me nobody's
ever asked me that question before
it's a bit cathartic
um
but I usually give them my answer first
to make them a little bit more
comfortable and I say for me is getting
married
I've been married and blessed 17 years
I love my wife
Derek who's here just met her since the
very beginning
and especially the first two years of
marriage for me
because it was a process of my relieving
myself of my ego
um and I didn't know it was the first
time in my life I had to start thinking
about things for two people instead of
one and that tension is Rich right
because it forced us to really think
about the values that were going to be
foundational and allow us to sustain
ourselves over that time 17 years
yeah I got married really really early
but we set that foundation so that now
our sons like we have shared language
to articulate to our sons why courage
matters why loyalty matters why
practicing good judgment Matters by
having faith matters so it was a real
good like transformative moment of
difficulty for me the reason I bring
that up because it's so personal
um but it actually like closes the
distance between me and the other person
in a way that I think is proven
productive and shows that person why
these values actually do matter to me
nobody ever did that to me so I thank
you for that I appreciate that
my wife's going to see that on YouTube
and be like oh
I love you
hi Tristan
my question is about the time in 2018
when you mentioned that you went through
some of the hardest time in your life
and there was a lot of pressure because
the company also was low on cash and
everything that was going through with
your personal life as well I'm curious
about how did the accusation when like
how did that come about because at the
same time you were thinking about this
is your baby this is your brand that
you've created and you wanted to go to a
company that would take it and make it
better yeah and not be in the pressure
of just selling it off because it's not
working out so what went through at that
time yeah it's a great great question I
am
the acquisition process is an
interesting one because I think a lot of
folks think about it as like big company
comes in takes small company right but
like we had agency in that discussion we
weren't only speaking to Procter Gamble
we were speaking to quite a few folks
right so for me it was like if if we
were going to do this and at that point
we kind of made the decision
um there's some terms that were going to
be important right you know I still
wanted to build something that was
around 100 years from now I never I
never said that I wanted to own it in
perpetuity right I just wanted to build
something that was still going to be
sustainable and support the community I
cared a lot about so that was important
number one is this does it have a
pathway to sustenance over the very long
term
two
the best way to prove it is to show me
that you've done it yourself
and you know you think about 180 years
of that kind of sustainability that at
least Procter Gamble anyway showed me
that they can do it if they wanted to
third autonomy
um you know I wanted to make sure that
we were still going to have the ability
to offer our point of view in the way
that was scalable so that required
setting up a system that enforces that
autonomy
um you know I I think I have a PNG email
address but I wouldn't even know how to
use it right
um you know we're a completely separate
entity we can't even take advantage of
their health insurance if we wanted to
we had to create our own right so
there's a system uh that really enforced
uh that autonomy for me
um and then lastly let me just kind of
wrap this in a bow and um to really talk
about on December 12th when we kind of
announced the acquisition something that
happened to me that I think made me a
better just leader on the other side now
it was the first time that I realized
what Freedom was
and and for me I Define Freedom as not
owing anybody anything
and it was the first time in my life I
felt that I didn't know investors
anything I didn't owe PNG anything right
um so it put me in a position where now
I can actually again have the agency to
show up in a way that the opportunity
deserved
and
it was important that whoever we were
merging with getting acquired by
respected it in every step of the way
PNG showed a respect for it and they
still do and it's the only reason I
still continue to be around
thank you
um thanks for coming where's that coming
from
oh
sorry I was having trouble standing no
problem
so thank you uh Serana NBA 2. so um I
was wondering at the GSB a lot of us
want to be Founders but it often feels
pretty daunting if you haven't done it
before
um so I was wondering how did you
convince others to believe in you as a
Founder maybe including becoming an eir
at entriesen yeah I mean first I'm going
to go back to the privilege thing only
reason in juice and hearts gave me the
opportunities because they wanted to
border Foursquare and I told them what I
wanted to do and they said that there's
an opportunity right so some of it is
access and information right but I'll be
honest like I still find myself having
to prove that Walking Company matters to
people
right that's just what Founders are
going to have to do and you know I
shared a little bit about the quality
around like
you know what makes you good in its
consistency
um but I'd add something there I think
the best Founders entrepreneurs whatever
you want to call it have stamina
um you just have to have the stamina to
know that like you're going to get a lot
of people to just say
your ideas crap or you can't do it
the only reason I got to where I did and
most of the reason why I was able to
raise the money that I was able to is
because I was in a position of privilege
that allowed me to
I couldn't fathom how difficult this
would be
and if I ever started another company
again I would not raise in the way that
I did I would not try to secure money
from the types of kind of investors that
I did because I know how hard it is and
I know how destructive it can be for
certain types of companies who are not
ready for it so some of this once you
realize that you want to be a Founder
there are a lot of
questions that require answers
do you want to raise money
if so why
are you understanding around the
trade-off of what comes with raising
money because you have to grow it and
return it
do you want to hire a lot of people and
manage a lot of people if so why and are
you comfortable and understanding around
what it means to hire and manage a lot
of people right so it's just not enough
to say you want to be a Founder but I
think asking the second and third and
fourth question around like do you
really want to run it
and I think that the more comfortable
you get with that
then the onus is on you because you've
made that decision for yourself that you
can't blame other people for and I found
myself
um blaming other people that I shouldn't
have because I wasn't thoughtful enough
in the beginning
hi Tristan my name is Maria and I'm Envy
too I've been very inspired to hear your
story how you became a leader in the cpg
industry and have created such a
groundbreaking product
I wanted to hear you know at such a
young age
um what's next on your career bucket
list how do you plan to leverage your
current position to
yeah
um
it's kind of unbelievable I'm even on
the stage right now it's like I am
I love my job
I love what I do every day I love the
people that I get to do it with and I
love the tribe being able to build right
and the the importance of like
um
why what we've built matters
you know I was sharing with a couple of
the previous classes that I was helping
teach that like there are only three
things that I've cared about that I
think explains every single thing that
I've done for my career the first is the
demographic shift happening this country
cultural influence of black people I
think I can't see myself being in a
position where I am not helping spread
that gospel
that like we matter in ways that most
people don't understand
uh second uh Technology's impact on that
right if you can apply technology in the
hands of curators of culture
fundamental power of that asset is
Meaningful beyond belief
and then lastly I love the development
of great brands
not just because they're cool but they
could be a force for good in the world
so everything that I've done for Walker
and Company code 24 they have the great
Fortune stood on the boards of like Foot
Locker Shake Shack et cetera
can really be explained by the
intersectionality of those three things
whatever I do today whatever I do
tomorrow will be the results of my kind
of situating myself in the middle
of those kind of intersection points
I could do anything with that right and
I think about the application of those
three things in every single industry
I think it's inevitably accretive
I'm trying to not be vague but vague at
the same time so I don't get in trouble
but but I I can only see myself doing
things that celebrate each of those
three things
we have time for one more
go ahead uh hi my name is Andrew I'm
curious
um
Andrew yeah have you managed to join two
like eventually a very very successful
startups while at business school
um I'm curious how did you identify that
these would be you know the next big
thing did you have a feeling for that
and especially curious about Foursquare
when you join the two people which is
very impressive yeah I don't start by
trying to think about what's going to be
the next big thing I just think about
doing things that improve my life and
lifestyle
you know Twitter improved my lifestyle
um like four square improved my
lifestyle
um and I was I think it's okay to be
selfish about that stuff right I can't
report this like being authentic and
living your own values and then say Oh
I'm going to chase the next big thing
right because who knows if it's going to
be the next big thing if you have enough
authenticity that tends to win itself
out every single time so for me I just
thought about the things that I was
using and it just happened to be those
things and more often than not your
classmates aren't chasing those same
things right because you were thoughtful
about why you liked them in the first
place
um so hopefully that answers the
question but like
I'm very selfish
about doing things that I like and you
should be too
wonderful well Tristan before you leave
it is a view from the top tradition to
close each session with a number of
Rapid Fire questions okay if you don't
mind I've prepared some for you cool
okay so to start off their Super Bowl is
coming up Eagles are Chiefs
[Laughter]
uh like I'm just worried about Rihanna
uh uh Eagles
okay very good
what was your favorite class at the GSB
oh it's Jeff effort is he still here uh
I I didn't take his class uh acting with
power but Deb Greenfield was my favorite
class
best piece of advice you've received
um Tyler Perry told me that the trials
you go through and the blessings you
receive are the exact same things that
stuck with me ever since okay the next
three are fill in the blank questions
okay
so my friends would describe me as
oh
handsome
I think
magnetic
okay
my next one was actually my wife would
describe me as
[Laughter]
um
she's gonna see this too
thoughtful okay and finally I would
describe myself as
um
consistent
wonderful you're very humble Tristan
thank you very much that's all the time
we have it's been a great pleasure
[Music]
[Applause]